well Tyree Nichols loved sunsets he was
a father he'd been able to photograph
The Twilight Sky and his home City of
Memphis with five black police officers
pulled him over the lady said it was for
reckless driving there's no evidence to
substantiate that it's still unclear why
they stopped him what is clear is that
Tyree Nichols was subjected to a Savage
and terrific beating taking sustained
blows from the officers as he cried out
for his mother and he died three days
later the beating was captured on body
Cam and CCTV in a warning viewers may
find this footage upsetting
what's up
well that is just what it looks like
it's five black officers beating a black
man horrific appalling incredibly hard
to watch not surprised by the global
revulsion to this brutality what I am
surprised by is the immediate attempts
by many high-profile liberal
commentators to blame this on racism and
white supremacy he is CNN commentator
van Jones
black people are at risk from police no
matter what color uh black white brown
you talk to African-Americans they'll
tell you
um it doesn't matter there's this
pervasive view from law enforcement that
if you're black or dangerous
really so black people killed a black
person
and that's racist well black lives
matter issued a statement saying that
all police represent the interests of
capitalism and impel State sanctioned
violence anyone who works within a
system of perpetuate State sanctioned
violence is complicit in upholding white
supremacy so these five black police
officers were white supremacists
apparently
Jamil Hill from the Atlantic agreed
explaining the entire system of policing
is based on white supremacist violence
again apparently nothing to do with just
five
horrible thugs wearing police uniforms
killing a black man it was apparently
about racism and white supremacy well
joining me now black lives matter
organizer and activist Iman ayton and
rapper and podcaster zubi welcome to
both of you Iman I don't get this
narrative at all that is coming out it's
been coming here from people as well but
somehow this is all about racism and
white supremacy it's not it's about five
poorly trained thuggish black police
officers killing a black man who did
nothing to deserve it that's it
okay so I just have to start with saying
that video was absolutely disgusting one
of the worst videos I've ever seen right
it goes on and on yeah it was disgusting
there was two versions of it the body uh
the body footage and the of course the
pole from across the road absolutely
disgusting so I'm absolutely horrified
at the fact that of course it was five
black people
um but for me personally this is about
an abuse of power and a disregard of
human life and those individuals need to
be accountable for their actions that I
need to don't disagree what's it got to
do with racism or white supremacy so
people why are white people responsible
for this okay so people could also argue
that this is due to internalized racism
which is a byproduct of societal or
institutional racism also referred to as
white supremacy so black police officers
become white supremacist
racists who kill black people
because they work in an atmosphere of
white supremacy is that it
I can explain it a little bit better
okay so anti-blackness is baked into
society here and in the US and black
people are not impervious to that and so
what people fail to realize people are
anti-black Yep this exactly is let me
explain so let me explain it let me
explain it peers so what people fail to
realize is that when black people have
to contend with racism they can end up
internalizing it and that can result in
low self-esteem self-loathing and
rejection of one's community and when
you combine those feelings which as we
know are also referred to as unconscious
bias when you have those feelings and
they are compounded by hierarchy and
power it can lead to an individual
abusing said power and projecting their
self-hate onto another and this is why
in my opinion why we see black and white
police officers killing more black
people than we do whites reason why is
because of racism which includes
internalized racism Pierce right I think
that's complete nonsense you're a white
man and you don't understand exactly I'm
white therefore my skin color means my
skin color means I have nothing to do
all right well let me go to a black man
and see if he's allowed to have a view
what's your view
okay so I agree with the first half of
everything that was said there I agree
that the video was disgusting I agree
that this is an issue of training and I
agree that this is an issue of the human
heart I think that any attempt to put
the blame on this in any way shape or
form on racism or white supremacy or
white people in general is absolutely
ridiculous I also think it's pretty
degrading because this sort of idea
stems from the notion that black people
black men black women that we do not
have full agency and responsibility and
therefore accountability for our actions
and our words we end up in these
ridiculous situations where no matter
their permutation no matter what happens
even if there's not a single white
person involved in this situation in the
Memphis police force even the police the
police chief is a black woman the large
percentage of the force is black and
people are still trying to lean on this
white supremacy is the answer and the
reason for everything and honestly it's
lame and as someone who's lived my
entire life as a as a black male uh
certainly I've never been possessed by
this sort of Phantom of of white
supremacy that's made me want to attack
anybody let alone another black person
and I think that we need to put the
blame and responsibility squarely on the
individuals who were involved I
completely agree tragic that this young
man died I completely agree I mean just
to note some statistics about the
Memphis Police Department that 65
percent of Memphis are population is
black 58 of the entire police Falls in
Memphis is black the police chief was a
black woman right and so on and so on so
you take all that totality you think
working well where is this
institutionalized white supremacy coming
from given the institution is actually
served predominantly by black people for
a population that is predominantly black
as well so I don't get that point the
second point I mentioned this I think
there's a wider issue here
the demonization of the police in
America
calling them all a bunch of vile races
has led to many older experienced good
police officers who are not via racists
quitting the force all over the country
and as a result in Memphis for example
they had a massive reduction 20 between
2011 and 2017 of police officers 20 off
went from the force
and so to try and restore the numbers
they made it easier to become a police
officer they reduced the restrictions
reduced to qualifications
two of the five officers involved in
killing this poor young man went through
that process in that period of not being
required to have the same
sort of qualifications that they used to
to join the Memphis Police Department so
you have a a bunch of people being
brought in who are poorly trained who
are not qualified to do the job who end
up committing this kind of crime that
has nothing to do with racism and white
supremacy that has everything to do I
think with perhaps an over-demonized
force in general with a lot of bad
apples in it but over demonized Force
leading to many people quitting and
being replaced with people just not up
to the job I think it's well everything
that you said I don't disagree with and
I think it's not about conflating the
two things it's just about presenting a
different perspective an alternative
perspective that should be considered
because internal racism is a real thing
so therefore it should be you've just
heard a black man yes a very considered
way say that basically you're talking
nonsense the idea that you said I'll ask
that says do you believe that internal
racism is nonsense do you believe that
black people cannot internalize racism
do you believe that
I don't believe that it's completely
impossible okay I don't think it's
impossible for that right I don't think
it's impossible for a person of any race
or ethnicity to Harbor hatred or
animosity towards people who may look
like them or share some things in common
what I don't what I completely disagree
with is the idea that in every single
one of these situations that no matter
what happens we just jump to white
supremacy as the problem you see we've
seen this happen many many times and I
agree with you I think one of the
biggest issues with it is okay I think
one of the biggest issues as well is
it's actually a distraction from a very
important conversation which appears was
leaning into there which is that when it
comes to the police in the USA and also
in other countries there's clearly an
issue of character qualifications
training I don't know exactly yeah and
Prejudice is the foundation for all Yes
exclamation including sexism misogyny
racism and the list goes on so if you
have not dealt with it again again
none of which had anything to do with
this particular incident what are you
talking about just explain to you
internal racism which is based off of
president had nothing to do with why
these and I said it should be consistent
I said it should be considered well
let's maybe finish the point you were
making
okay the the okay even following on from
that point I'd also say this is mind
reading as well so even trying to bring
racism into this conversation let's say
these guys did not have guns and badges
let's say these was this was just a
group of random thugs five black men
beating up another black man even in
that situation even outside the police
force I've still seen situations where
people try to blame this somehow on this
Specter of white supremacy and as I've
said frankly it's embarrassing and
that's a black person I have just as
much agency and accountability okay
um as I said black people have full
responsibility and accountability just
like it would be ridiculous to see a
video of white people beating up a white
man there are videos out there of white
police beating up white people I would
also make the point yeah
that if people genuinely believed it was
racism then given these scenes were as
horrific as the George Floyd killing in
my in my view no no better no worse I
mean this was went on for a much longer
period and was disgusting and abhorrent
to watch completely innocent guy just
getting beaten and then he died
um that given that if it was racism that
people genuinely believed was the
motivation we would see the same scenes
on the streets of cities All Over
America that we saw after George Floyd's
death we would see the riots we would
see burning cities we would see that
kind of intensity of reaction but the
truth is even the people claiming this
is about racism they don't believe it
because if they didn't believe that if
they did believe that they'd be out in
the streets saying it and they're not
saying it they are saying it because
they do believe it but they're not
protesting in the same way because in
their hearts they know it's not right I
agree with you in that I've always said
that I don't subscribe to any type of
democracy right so if white people are
going to kill black people we should be
outraged if black people kill black
people who should be outraged so
therefore there are many things that
should be have said that I agree there
are many things that you have said that
I agree of but what I'm also trying to
say is that firstly this is about abuse
of power and a disregard of Life those
individuals should have uh should make
sure that they're they're they are
accountable for them we can all agree on
that that is clear but we also need to
need to take into account that black
people internalize racism and they can
perpetuate that racism within
institutions that is the fact yeah I'll
tell you what is a fact this was five
black police officers killing a black
man not because of racism and white
supremacy or because anything a white
person but because they actually didn't
know how to do their jobs he got
completely out of control they behave
like a mob a frenzied mob just like and
they completely lost and they completely
lost control as well when white police
beat up you know what they're also thugs
as well because black people aren't just
thugs when they beat up black people I
didn't say black people can also be
perceived as sponsors
you can keep saying whatever you want
this had nothing to do with racism or
white supremacy and as zooby right I
actually think it's embarrassing didn't
you they were black thugs okay but you
don't call white people
can I say one more thing
I call White thugs white thugs there is
far more and first what I'm talking
about there's far more emphasis this is
this normality of media
uh connotations like [__] final words
yeah can I can I jump in here I I think
I I think that in all of our in in both
the US and in the UK when we can have
these conversations without the words
white and black even being brought into
the picture then I think we'll be making
something that's a serious conversation
color blind I actually completely agree
with that I'm beautiful
he talked about the police brutality
here in that context without mentioning
skin care we would actually get
somewhere to trying to help the
situation but by making it about race
where it doesn't exist we actually cause
more problems
appreciate you joining me thank you very
much good to have on the show